Ayesha, your magazine, Sweet July,
highlights changemakers, which I just love.
And then we heard about a flower shop
in Oklahoma City that was changing the lives
of the homeless in their community,
and then we thought maybe this is a perfect match.
Absolutely, just the coolest.
Okay, let's meet them, take a look.
Hi, Drew, my name is Ranya.
And I'm Jordan, we've been friends
since elementary school and together we run
Curbside Flowers.
Back on Valentine's Day in 2016,
we, along with The Homeless Alliance,
had the idea to start creating and selling bouquets
of flowers as a way to provide work
and income to people in our city experiencing homelessness.
We've received so much love
and support from the community and at the same time,
we are raising awareness and putting a face
to the issue of homelessness in Oklahoma City.
We want to help people see someone
beyond just the problem that they faced.
Flowers are beautiful and so are people.
And if we work together as a community,
we can help our neighbors in their homelessness.
Thanks, Drew, can't wait to talk to you soon.
Wow, Ranya and Jordan are joining Ayesha and I now.
Hi, guys.
(audience loudly cheering)
Hi, Ayesha.
Hi, hi, you guys!
So nice to meet you.
So cool.
Thank you so much for coming here today.
Your operation looks just beautiful.
Can you explain the impact
that your organization is having
on your community right now?
Curbside Flowers is a program of The Homeless Alliance
and we operate just like any traditional flower shop,
but we are a nonprofit and we employ people transitioning
out of homelessness in our community.
So we are helping remove barriers to employment for folks
so that they can earn income, build job skills,
and regain stability in their lives.
We have also teamed up with a local college
so that our participants can earn certifications,
which is such an incredible experience for them.
We employ 10 people in our flower shop year-round
but seasonally at Valentine's Day, like this week,
we get to hire additional employees.
So this Valentine's Day,
we are working with 45 additional people
working to end their-
(audience loudly applauding)
Wow!
That's amazing.
And Jordan, you have a goal this Valentine's Day, right?
We do, our goal was to hit 2000 bouquets
and we are just a few hundred away from that.
What you guys are doing is so incredible and inspiring
and you guys yourselves are changemakers.
And so I feel like we wanted
to help you guys meet that goal, right, Drew?
Yes, absolutely, Ayesha.
Ranya, this Valentine's Day,
you set a goal of the 2000 bouquets
and you said you were a few hundred off, right?
Yes, we're a couple hundred away
from meeting that at this moment.
Well, Ayesha and I would like to buy two bouquets
and we'd like to pay $5,000 for those bouquets,
just so that you have a little extra
to get you where you need to go
and we're gonna feature you
on the DrewBarrymore.com website
to drive traffic to you this Valentine's Day.
Thank you, guys!
Thank you so much!
So, so much and that is incredible, thank you so, so much.
Excellent, and Ayesha,
when I look at your and Steph's body of work
in the philanthropic category, it is dauntingly incredible
the impact you're having on the world at large,
your country, and your community.
What is maybe when you do a changemaker highlight
in your magazine, do you have any suggestions
for someone who just wants to do one thing
in maybe their community?
Absolutely, I feel like people always feel
like it needs to be so big and grandiose
and it really doesn't.
I truly believe in the cup-of-sugar model.
So, bringing that neighbor a cup of sugar,
a small act like that.
So any small little thing that you can do
to help out your community, because that person
in turn is gonna bake a cake
that's gonna feed the community and so on and so forth.
And so it really is a domino effect
where one small step to change can really
actually make a huge difference.
And so never feel like any act of kindness
or change is too small.
I so agree.
(audience loudly applauding)
Also, ladies, Ranya and Jordan,
I heard that you guys like Flower Home
so I wanted to give you a $1000 gift card
because you know, flower, flower, flower.
Thank you so much, Drew.
Thank you so, so much.
That will definitely go to good use in our office space.
Perfect, I just want to thank you guys
for joining Ayesha and I, and please,
go to our website at TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com
to learn more about Curbside Flowers, thank you ladies.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
And Ayesha,
I have really been looking forward to meeting you.
Thank you so much, I appreciate it so much
and you've inspired me.
And so I appreciate, I appreciate the kind words.
And Sweet July's spring issue is out today.
It is just incredible.
Thank you!
The Full Plate also, best cookbook ever, is available now.
You probably already own it,
but if you're in the Bay Area,
stop by Ayesha's Sweet July shop
and for more information on Eat, Learn, Play,
go to our website on TheDrewBarrymoreShow.com.
We'll have that all up there.
And before we all go, we have another Galentine's Day treat.
All of our VFFs are getting a $100 Spafinder gift card
that can be redeemed for spa services
and salons nationwide, found on Spafinder.com.
So, Happy Valentine's Day, and thank you, Spafinder.
Ayesha, thank you for being here, it's a real honor.
(upbeat music)